i feel bad because i don't feel like
kissing you
you don't want to kiss me do you do you
know which actress was stuck kissing a
co-star with a terrible cold
their on-screen chemistry was amazing
but these actors were dreading the
moment they'd have to lock lips
whether it was co-stars who felt like
siblings or the
onions they had for lunch these actors
pushed past the discomfort to bring
these romantic moments to life
i got up and then i said kissing sucks
eleven and mike are the perfect example
of
young love in stranger things but millie
bobby brown described her first kiss
with finn wolfhard as
the most awkward thing in the world
there were like 200 people in the room
just stabbed
also like my parents were there the most
awkward part for millie was that her dad
was watching her get her very first kiss
on camera
finn also admitted that his skills
weren't the greatest
it looked like i was eating her like i
was like ah
but the awkwardness ended up making the
scene more believable
and the pair has since gotten more
comfortable with their on-screen
chemistry
we've progressed we've gotten better
yeah they're good kissers
kissing robert pattinson might seem like
a dream come true
but while filming water for elephants he
had a terrible cold that made kissing
him straight up disgusting
you're really envy of so many women in
the world she's like actually it was one
of the most repulsive things
that ever happened pattinson even fessed
up to wiping his nose on her wig at one
point
reese went on to describe him as
literally snorting and snotting through
every second of it
i've never had a love scene with a
person that sick
fans were hesitant when friends tried
the whole rachel and joey romance thing
but no one felt more awkward than
jennifer aniston
and matt leblanc matt was against it
because he knew joey would never date
someone ross had been in love with
he also had a brotherly relationship
with jennifer in real life
and in the show so kissing the actress
was not an attractive idea
jen also pointed out that ross made the
whole situation awkward
she finally agreed but only if the
storyline was about a crush
not the friends falling in love these
romantic scenes in silver linings
playbook
are not exactly what they seemed bradley
cooper revealed that jennifer lawrence
did not enjoy kissing him on the graham
norton show he admitted that
after the second take she said you're a
wet kisser
you don't want to hear that it was not a
compliment
however it couldn't have been too
terrible or his skills improved since
the pair went on to star
and kiss in other films divergent stars
shailene woodley and miles teller looked
like they were enjoying themselves in
the spectacular now
but both stars admitted that those
kissing scenes were
uncomfortable shailene has a
naturalistic lifestyle
including brushing her teeth with clay
and taking herbal supplements
which miles really didn't enjoy tasting
meanwhile
shailene was grossed out by miles
drinking gatorade and eating chocolate
the co-stars made their kissing aversion
into a weird game
with miles revealing we put stuff in our
mouths so we could just
offend each other how about a throwback
to our disney channel days
when ashley tisdale and zac efron locked
lips in the suite life of zack and cody
it was like a high school musical
alternate reality but for ashley it was
her
worst on-screen kiss and it's the worst
because i'm so close to him and he's
like my brother
zack also tried to take things up a
notch she tried
to kissing me with this and i was like
get away from me no matter how
attractive ryan reynolds is
we can understand why marina background
didn't enjoy kissing him as deadpool
she described kissing him during those
scenes as it basically just smells like
rubber the entire time she also said it
was hard to feel romantic and connected
with him
in the costume when i looked at his face
it was hard
harder to connect with him with the
person
it even took two full days of shooting
to get through the couple's intimate
scenes in the movie
thanks to ryan's perfectionism i was so
annoyingly specific about everything in
this film
it's not easy working with a co-star who
you used to date
just ask penn badgley the gossip girl
star admitted that blake lively was both
his best
and worst kiss i'll say it was blake
because we actually had a relationship
at the time and then and then the worst
maybe blake after we broke up the stars
managed to remain professional on set
after their breakup
and penn gave himself and blake some
praise for being able to push past the
discomfort
you know it's like is anything is
complicated in that way and i and
um we handled it to everyone's surprise
angelina jolie's wanted co-star james
mcavoy
did not enjoy kissing the actress mcavoy
revealed
it was awkward sweaty and not very nice
to make things more awkward the kiss was
the first scene they filmed together
mcavoy also told the today show that
like most movie kisses
it was anything but romantic you end up
doing it first thing
just after you've had like you know your
breakfast and you're all kind of funky
in the mouth
for this iconic spider-man kiss kirsten
dunst took toby maguire's breath away
but not in a good way maguire revealed
in a parade magazine interview that he
had
rain water running up my nose then when
kirsten rolled back the wet mask
she cut off the air completely he also
said it was more like giving her
mouth-to-mouth
rather than kissing her while filming
the hunger games
liam hemsworth thought jennifer lawrence
was trolling him by eating smelly foods
before their kissing scenes and
not brushing her teeth before the scene
she'd be like yeah i had tuna i had
garlic and i didn't brush my teeth later
jennifer responded saying she actually
didn't do it on purpose
i didn't change the way i was eating for
the kissing which is different than
eating something on purpose is it worse
we're not
sure do you think that's worse than
doing it on purpose
both nicole kidman and hugh jackman were
married while filming the 2008 movie
australia
elle reported that jackman didn't look
forward to kissing kidman
saying it's never particularly
comfortable making out with someone in
front of 70 people
but what really made it awkward was that
his wife deborah lee freness
was very close friends with nicole they
even used to live together
he told express needless to say deb
wasn't on set when we had our kissing
scenes
kirsten dunst thought her quick kiss
with brad pitt in interview with a
vampire was
disgusting she was only 12 while filming
the movie
and like all kids thought kissing in
general was just gross
especially with brad who felt like
family brad was like my older brother on
the sentence kind of like
kissing your brother i don't know
looking back she doesn't consider it her
first real kiss
i did have a first kiss as a normal
young adult
emma watson and rupert grint dreaded
kissing in harry potter so much
that they refused to let daniel
radcliffe even be on set
with them everyone was there for my kids
they both found it incredibly awkward
because they were such close friends and
felt like brother and sister
you've grown up with them being put in a
situation where you have to kiss them is
just
really awkward there was also a lot of
pressure to get it right
since fans had been waiting for this
moment for what felt like forever
there's so much anticipation with these
two because it has been building up
thankfully they pushed past how
uncomfortable they were to deliver
the perfect on-screen kiss and plenty of
bloopers for us to enjoy too
leonardo dicaprio had to kiss plenty of
women in the wolf of wall street but
only one
made him nervous kissing english
national treasure joanna lumley
the scene where he's kissing his wife's
aunt to get what he wants
makes us all a little uncomfortable but
dicaprio and lumley felt
even worse the actress revealed they
kissed about 15
times and that it's actually no fun
kissing actors
no fun at all there are so many takes
and you both have to chew
so much chewing gum we were just really
clean like a kind of
you know like a surgery really really
clean excellent surgery
props to these actors for pulling off
amazing chemistry despite
awkward situations but what about some
of our favorite star's
best on-screen kisses you'll be happy to
know that zac efron
loved kissing zendaya in the greatest
showman saying that just a glance
between their characters felt electric
and that definitely came across on
screen